- Good morning, Believe Nation!
Today's message is Be Yourself.
Over to you, Ariana Grande.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Be yourself, you know,
in your most genuine possible way
and are completely unafraid
that's when everything
starts to fall into place.
And that takes a while.
Especially with so much
public, like, you know,
rumors, and opinions,
and all that stuff.
- Of course.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- It's like, you get scared
and you want to hold back a little
but then I was like, you know what?
None of this would be
happening if I would just show,
just was like, gah,
and just was myself when I went out
and I was my silly self.
(Interviewer chuckles)
And then you go,
and it all goes away,
and then you're like, that's me
and if you don't like it I go.
- It's a life changer.
- Yeah, when you let go
and you're like, here you go.
Take it or leave it.
- Whether you like it or not.
- That's as simple
as it can be.
Why hold back?
You want life.
Just have fun and be yourself
and don't worry about the rest.
It all falls into place.
- You will never do great things
if you hold yourself back.
The faster you understand who you are,
what that looks like,
and you have the confidence to express it,
that's when great things start to happen.
I often get asked
in interviews and questions,
what would I give advice
to my 20 year old self.
And normally, I don't have
a lot of things to say
because I don't live with regret.
I'm really happy where I'm at now
and that's accumulation of all the things
that have happened in my life.
But if there was one thing
that I would tell myself, going back,
is to just believe more,
to have more self-confidence,
to take that idea that I had
and do something with it.
And I think we all have
these ideas inside ourselves,
we have these things
that we want to express,
these things we want to create.
the song you want to write,
the business you want to start,
whatever it is.
You have that thing inside you
and you don't know how
to articulate it well
cause you never done it before,
cause you're afraid,
you don't have the skillset,
you don't have the connections.
You've never done it before!
So there's a lot of nervousness.
And so that fear prevents
you from getting started.
That fear prevents you from doing it.
If I look at my Youtube Channel,
when I started it,
there was profiles of
successful entrepreneurs,
there was me answering
questions from different people,
entrepreneurs writing in.
And I was consistent-ish.
And then when I started
taking it seriously,
that's when I started getting better.
That's when I started discovering myself.
That's when I found my voice.
And you can learn from
all these other people
and model success, I'm a big fan of it,
but at the end of the day,
you have to find the
thing that works for you.
And that comes from practicing.
So when you have that next thought,
when you have that next idea,
when you have that next
thing that you want to do,
don't just sit on it.
Get tired of sitting on things.
Get tired of just building
up a list of to do's
that never get done.
I want people to look at my videos
and say, "That, Evan
Carmichael made that."
We've developed that style now.
People will look at,
it's not just a logo
and it's not just the Top 10 Rules.
People will look at a video
and know that this is
the style that I want,
this is the style that I made.
I want you to find that.
I want you to stop fitting in.
I want you to stop being vanilla.
I want you to go more
aggressively in on yourself
and what you can do.
Take those ideas that you have
and start to express them.
And understand in the beginning,
it's not going to be perfect.
You're going to make a lot of mistakes.
You won't find your path yet.
It may start by copying other people.
But as you do it more,
as you build the consistency up,
you will find a unique path
that has never been taken before.
And the more you get used to
building up the confidence
and courage to follow that path,
the bigger that path becomes
and the more success awaits you
at the end of the road.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious,
what is uniquely you in your business?
What would people look at and say,
"That is unique to you"?
What's your trademark?
What is the thing that you
bring that's so different?
I'm super curious to find out.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Aviv Oren.
Aviv, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word.
Really, really, really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I hope you have an amazing day.
I believe in you
and hope we're getting you
to believe in yourself.
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going.
(typewriter clicking)
- Don't become like a cult.
Don't just like me.
Be a fan of everyone.
You can like Rihanna's
music, and mine, and Gaga's.
It's okay.
You don't have to be like,
"I'm a Jessie J Fan
and that's all (roars)"
(audience laughs)
You know, and my mum and dad
would never let me put posters on the wall
because they were like,
"Be you.
Be inspired but don't become anyone else."
Which is why I think, as an artist,
I was very, very,
The one thing I was very proud of
is when I first came out, that every,
no one compared me to anyone.
I think you can tell when someone's
idolized somebody, sometimes.
And I think it's good to be inspired
but don't become somebody.
Be yourself.
Just always be yourself.
Always.
(gentle piano music)
Whatever people say about you,
whatever people believe
that is true, that isn't about you.
Trust me.
Life is not worth living
feeling sad, and down, and lonely.
Just always be true to who you are.
- I'm more worried now
about being true to myself
and being honest.
And you know, maybe 10 years ago
I would have not done
a video like She Wolf
but now, it's something I
feel like doing, you know?
So why am I going to deprive myself from,
or deny myself the possibility
of expressing
the way I feel.
I want to express myself freely.
I don't want to be in
a golden cage anymore.
I don't want to be put behind bars.
I think we,
This life is so brief
and we spend it sometimes
imposing over ourselves
so many limitations
and obstacles that don't allow us
to grow as we would like to, you know?
And yes, I feel very much like a woman
and this time around
I wanted to show my legs,
I never show my legs
for 20 years, (laughs)
(Katie laughs)
And I always, I always did my performances
with long pants and,
believe it or not, I never showed my legs.
And one day I looked at them and say,
hey, they're not bad.
They're kind of short but
they take me to places.
I think it's now or
never, you know? (laughs)
So I did it.
It's about time to really
embrace my individuality
and my freedom as a woman, as a person.
And that's a message that
I encourage to other women.
That doesn't mean
necessarily letting yourself
being objectified
because that means satisfying
the desires of other people.
I say, satisfy your own desires
and live your life to the fullest
because it's short.
- I'm not pretending to be something
that I'm not
or pretending to be this
goody two-shoes or whatever.
I'm just being myself.
And I think that then
nobody can be disappointed
with who I am as a person
or I don't feel like I
have to hide or pretend
because I'm not, I'm not,
I'm just being Zendaya.
You know?
And I'm just going through life
and learning out, you know,
learning how to be a young woman
and it just, you know,
I have that responsibility.
I think it's a responsibility.
Is it a little bit of a weight sometimes?
Absolutely,
but it's a responsibility that--